por primera vez desde que comenzó la
pandemia alemania registró más de 10.000
nuevos casos de coronavirus en 24 horas
una cifra muy preocupante para las
autoridades en este país que han tenido
dificultades en las últimas semanas para
ponerse de acuerdo sobre las medidas
necesarias a nivel nacional para frenar
el aumento en el número de casos de
coronavirus un aumento que se manifiesta
de manera muy particular en las grandes
ciudades como aquí en la capital berlín
entre las medidas que han sido
anunciadas están limitar el número
máximo de personas que pueden reunirse
en zonas consideradas de alto riesgo así
como ampliar el uso del tapabocas en
lugares públicos aunque por supuesto las
autoridades también han hecho énfasis en
la necesidad de que las personas
mantengan las distancias y cumplan con
las medidas que han sido anunciadas y
para complicar aún más las cosas en
alemania la noticia de los más de 10.000
casos en 24 horas llega poco después de
que el ministro de salud y en espa quien
ha sido la cara visible del gobierno en
todo el tema de la pandemia en los
últimos meses diera positivo por
coronavirus